en medio de la noche repetidas
explosiones resuenan en el centro de
kiev
el ejército ucraniano dijo que había
repelido varios avances rusos hacia la
capital aunque no hubo confirmaciones
inmediatas de pérdidas por parte de
moscú esto se produjo después de que el
presidente por el emir selenski diera un
discurso a medianoche diciendo a los
ucranianos que se prepararán para un
asalto de mosca
no podemos perder la capital me dirijo a
nuestros defensores esta noche en todos
los frentes el enemigo utilizará todas
sus fuerzas a su disposición para romper
nuestra resistencia y si hay aviones de
forma deshonesta cruel e inhumana vídeos
cortos y netbooks las autoridades han
instado a los ciudadanos a tomar las
armas y defender el país el ministerio
del interior incluso distribuye
instrucciones para fabricar cócteles
molotov
nos dieron armas en la oficina de
registro militar como voluntarios
militares ahora la situación es tan
terrible que no hay tiempo para esperar
una convocatoria formal
según la onu el conflicto ha desplazado
ya a más de 100.000 personas en ucrania
casi la mitad de ellas a otros países